yeah andy how are you i'm good
yeah i'm in a good mood i sure am all
right i understand you uh
you had a little assignment recently i
did um
uh with with tax time or tax day the
cutoff day
being monday that's right it was just it
was actually just this monday
was the final deadline right midnight
monday
so i went down to the uh main branch of
the post office here in manhattan on
eighth avenue uh-huh and it was a circus
a media circus
just a plain old circus i've actually
heard about this people
coming in at the last second to get
their uh they get their taxes in like
down to the minute yeah they're they're
on the floor doing their taxes they're
all over the place it's really
a zoo you know uh-huh okay and you you
brought a camera crew that's right
and you have a little report to file yes
i do all right ladies and gentlemen
let's get into it right now
andy richter's visit to the post office
here in new york on
tax day at the very last second let's
roll with dana
on tax day we're here at the main post
office in new york city
and we came down to sort of get a
feeling for the
event and it really is an event which
i'm
i'm glad about because you know they
told me to come down talk to people
about their taxes i thought
why but um i didn't
i don't know i'm a touchy subject with
me this year because i owed a lot of
money and it was sort of what was nbc's
fault
uh withholding i i'm not going to get
into it so we'll
we'll just go in there see why these
stragglers
have waited so long hi
i'm here with jeff haskins and jeff
why did you put it off till now because
i owe money
i guess i you know always put things off
and just
it came down to the last minute and here
i am
i'm an actress and um this is a very
busy time
um for actors and actresses because it's
the um
summer season coming up so there are a
lot of auditions going on for summer
stock
nbc wasn't withholding my new york city
tax so they because i get a check to an
agent in la and
do you have any sort of prepared
monologue that maybe you'd like to just
do a little piece of
think of it as an audition nationally
when are you going to get this chance
okay
hi i'm sarah
i bet you'd like me to tell you
something about myself right
something interesting and exciting
something interesting and exciting
something interesting and exciting
rather than having it pulled out of my
check throughout the year
i end up having to pay this huge lump
sum and i mean if they had
if they had let me know i could have
adjusted my lifestyle
i told my cousin i didn't want a bird i
hate birds
she swore i'd love a parakeet what's to
love they don't do anything except not
sing when you want them to
sing when you don't and make those awful
scratching noises on that awful
sandpaper on the floor of their cell i
mean cage
i bet you're a bird lover yeah it
i was going to go to greece this summer
and i can't now i was going to take a
vacation with my wife three back rubs
don't let uncle sam rub you the wrong
way three
back rubs it's a lot of money i'm i'm
paying a lot of money to the government
and it's
it's nbc's fault pretty much
and uh i was gonna go on vacation
oh
what do you guys do for a living we're
tax lawyers oh so this is sort of like a
morbid fascination oh yeah this is this
is like a
mortician showing up to a funeral are
you gonna sort of like rib people
no no we would never do that
if i ever have another pet it'll be a
dog something that shows a little
enthusiasm when you walk through the
door
something you can hold the only time i
got my hands on that stupid parakeet was
the day it dropped dead
and i had to pick it up and throw it in
the garbage can
thank you
i mean you kind of gotta wonder why
people do this to themselves i mean
sitting on the floor doing their taxes
it's tax time and here i am at the post
office
doing the same it's tax time story that
i did last year
you see i'm being punished for my
shenanigans at the christmas party
i'll probably be doing this tax time
story for the rest of my life
tax time blah blah blah tax time blah
blah blah
back to you kip
man that's nbc for you look at him what
a dynamic
shot he's strolling through
that really gets a feel look at the abc
guy just stood there
and i'm here doing a story about
people doing their taxes
i'm noticing them making fun of me
and he's turning away so the big
reporter man doesn't see him making fun
of him
i'm also supposedly a marcia clark
look-alike
oh really actually we'll take note of
that
well thank you you're welcome thank you
very much andy
okay thank you
we'll get her work yeah nice job thank
you
the reporter didn't find out uh well
not till now not till now all right
folks we're gonna do is gonna take a
quick break when we come back
father guido